during a segment on Fox news about democratic
presidential contender, Pete booted Jed, his
marriage to his husband, a Fox news anchor
cutoff contributor, Jessica Tarlov
saying it's not appropriate for you to bring
up the personal relationships of Donald Trump
and countless Fox news
viewers failed to see this incredible double
standard.
This was a segment about Pete Buddha judge's
personal relationship during which someone
tried to bring up Trump's personal relationship
and was told it's not okay to mention Trump's
personal relationship.
Check this out, and the context is right wing
radio host rush Limbaugh's recent homophobic
comments about Pete Buddha, judge.
We'll pick it up there.
You will see Jessica Tarlov, a Fox news contributor
bring up Trump's relationships and it all
just goes haywire and she's told that's not
okay.
That's inappropriate.
Jessica.
So notice that the Republican on the panel
doesn't want to talk about what the substance
of the criticism was, which was a homophobic
comment made by rush Limbaugh there.
It's really interesting to me as someone who
is an open advocate obviously for same sex
marriage, which is now the law of the land.
Um, thankfully a lot of work there by Joe
Biden to do that.
But you, when you hear these criticisms from
the right, and this has been consistent even
going from bill BARR saying that Progressive's
or the secular laughter, Mo responsible for
the moral decay of the country and you see
a loving monogamous couple like people to
judge and Chastin, his husband out there showing
what is possible that someone who is in a
same sex relationship could be running for
president and doing this well.
And then they're torn down by rush Limbaugh,
who's been married four times.
I think we have Donald Trump three times married,
cheated on all of those wives.
And you hear these personal relationships,
but we could, we could say exactly what it
is that racial boss says so that it's fair
in the conversation here.
Let's
not bring up personal relationships.
Says anchor Sandra Smith.
Is this satire?
Is this a parody?
The entire segment is about the personal relationship
of Pete Buddha judge, which became a topic
of homophobic iron for rush Limbaugh and Jessica
Tarlov, who I'm, I'm not a particular fan
of hers in the sense that I don't know who
she is.
She says, if rush wants to talk about relationships,
what about his three or four marriages?
What about rush supporting Donald Trump?
Who's cheated on every spouse he's had?
No, no, no, no, no.
Let's not bring personal relationships into
this.
I wish Jessica Tarlov had immediately said,
guys, this whole segment is about personal
relationships.
This entire thing is about Pete booted judge's
personal relationship and rush Limbaugh's
opinion of Pete booted judge's personal relationship
and you guys are all hypocrites, but then
she may be, wouldn't be a Fox news contributor
anymore and I guess we're forgetting the real
important difference here.
Buddha judge is a gay Democrat.
While Trump is their Lord and savior, alpha
male, Republican president.
That's really the difference here and this
is considered journalism among some people.
People are at least sort of smart, incisive
commentary.
That's how far we've fallen and as I was watching
this, I watched it a couple of times in preparation
for today's segment.
When you learn to think critically, lots of
things go out the out the window news is one
of them.
When you learn to think critically, uh, astrology
no longer makes sense to you.
When you learn to think critically, supply
side, trickle down economics don't make sense
anymore.
A multilevel marketing for moms wanting to
start their own business, working from home,
that stops making sense when you start applying
critical thinking in your life.
Timeshare seminars stop making sense when
you think critically and in this time of hypocrisy
saying you can't talk about personal relationships
during a segment exclusively about the personal
relationship of a candidate that stops making
sense real quick when you're thinking critically,
but when you're not thinking critically, this
stuff apparently makes sense to you.
Coming up next on Fox news, a segment about
hypocrisy during which you can't mention Donald
Trump.
That's effectively what we're talking about
here.
And you all know I'm not a Pete boot edge
edge supporter.
Everybody I think who has been watching this
show for a while knows that although I'd vote
for him over Trump of course, but just imagine
for a second if on January whatever, 2021
inauguration day, imagine Pete, Buddha, judge
and his husband dancing at the inaugural ball.
These people's heads would explode and that
would be something to see.
Now, it's not enough to get me to support
boot edge in the primary, but if he is indeed
the nominee, I will vote for him and I will
look forward to the exploding heads when he
dances with Chastin at the inaugural ball.